hello gorgeous girl
hello you
did you expect her to give you all the
feel i will say i was never like a big
baby person and then
i had my baby and it's just changed the
way i look at other babies now running
from my old ways old days
congratulations on your new song blessed
and free i'm a huge fan of her i've
interviewed her before she's so cool how
did this whole collaboration come up
well it's funny because my wife is a
huge fan of her and that's what
introduced me to her best part
that was our first dance song
[Music]
i wrote this song like i want to say two
and a half or three years ago it was
just kind of sitting on the side for a
little while and then my manager texted
me and said that her jumped on it and
wrote her own verse and i just started
freaking out because i knew my wife
loved her and then when i listened to it
like she just slayed this on so
[Music]
and kane's blessed free tour will take
over toronto scotiabank arena the
raptors home court this november we know
that drake is a huge toronto raptors fan
if you were going to go one-on-one with
him in a game who do you think would win
me
no question huh whole question i've
watched some videos of them playing not
pressed i'm not not impressed i just i
just
[Applause]
[Music]